[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Next up for our auto advancing
slides is Wolff Dobson.
He's told me to warn you all
that he'll probably be talking
like the Micro Machines guy.
So this'll be great.
Ready?
WOLFF DOBSON: Hello.
Oops, sorry.
OK.
I'm Wolff Dobson.
I'm a developer of
programs engineer.
And I'm going to
talk to you about
bite-sized virtual reality.
I'm going to talk really
fast, so let's all just enjoy
this moment of zen
until it auto-advances.
All right.
Cardboard was
Google's surprise way
to have virtual
reality experiences
just with the phone
in your pocket
and a few dollars' worth
of folded cardboard.
We've been pushing the
entry cost for developers
to get into mobile VRs way down.
I'm going to talk a
lot about Cardboard.
But first, I'm going to talk
about the uncanny valley.
The uncanny valley is
the idea that things
that look kind of human are OK.
As you get closer
and closer to human,
it starts getting
a little weird.
Right.
Oh god, I hate those guys.
And it can be really creepy.
This is the uncanny valley.
And on the left, you've got
industrial robots and really
nice cartoons you like.
And on the right, you have real
humans, which everybody likes.
And then right in
the middle there
is the uncanny valley where--
oh god, that guy again!
[LAUGHTER]
I hate that guy.
I'm going to posit the
same thing exists about VR.
This is a pleasantness
curve that
shows all the possible
experiences of VR
on various kinds of hardware.
The left, low-fidelity stuff, on
the right, super high-fidelity
matrixy stuff.
And in the middle,
there's this awkward thing
where you're going to
get weird looking stuff
like screen door visuals,
and motion sickness,
and tracking latency.
They're all emblematic of
that big dip in the VR valley.
When you're gunning for
sensory replacement,
you're telling people that
they're in another place.
And you're teleporting them
to this alternate reality.
The problem is every time
you deviate from reality--
any kind of frame lag
or sensor freezes--
it'll make you unhappy.
It makes you
recognize that you're
wearing some kind of
weird-looking mask
with the screen smashed
up against your face.
And that can be a
little off-putting.
So Cardboard and similar
low-cost VR experiences
live comfortably on the
near side of the VR valley.
These experiences
aren't cut-down versions
of high-grade VR.
They're just their
own experience
that has a different kind
of set of affordances.
So as this lovely woman in a
matching phone and sweater set
will tell you--
[LAUGHTER]
--she's holding this
device up to her face.
And her eyes can't turn
any faster than her spine.
And she's also holding
her hands up to her face,
which gives her this
feeling like she's
peering into something.
And a peering mentality is
a very different experience
than feeling like
you're teleporting.
It's like you're looking
into something, not replacing
your entire sensory
field, like an SLR camera
or, say, this 1861
megalethoscope that I
found in a Stanford museum.
So the point of all this is
holding Cardboard to your face
is not an infinite thing.
You're going to put it down
because we don't have a strap.
You're going to like--
[SIGH] my arms are tired.
So what we're calling
this is bit-sized VR.
So let's take a
look at an example
that you have right now.
Those of you who have
Google Maps on your phone
can try this yourself.
This is just
regular Google Maps.
If you click on
Street View, you'll
see that you can
see Street View.
And if you tap on this little
button in the lower left,
you're in Look
Around mode, which
is you're using the
gyroscope to show
where you are in the space.
If I double tap on that
button, it actually
puts it in VR mode,
which is really cool.
And you should all try it.
And outside of the fact that
that's really mind-blowing
that this is in your
pocket right now
and you can access
it any time you want,
the thing that's
cool about is when
you're done looking, you
can just hit the Back button
and pop right back into 2D
land, where you can go back
to doing this manipulation
like Maps does
and go and find something else
to look at besides Notre Dame.
So what about your mobile game?
You might not be ready to run
your entire game in VR right
now.
You many not have the controls
optimized around gaze.
You might not have the commit
to performance on side-by-side
rendering.
But there's still a bunch
of really interesting things
you can do.
So imagine you're making
a first-person shooter.
For an onlooker, you might
want to make an experience
like being a security camera.
You are in a stationary place.
So your controls
are pretty easy,
and you're just looking around
watching everybody shoot
at each other.
I think that's
going to be awesome.
Another thing is
if you're making
"Kerbal Space Program" or some
other kind of game like that.
I want to actually, after I'm
finished building my spaceship,
actually stand on the
spaceship and look at things.
That would be totally awesome.
Likewise,
"RollerCoaster Tycoon"--
totally want to
experience what it's like
to ride on a roller coaster
that I've built myself.
The trick is that you can mix
2D and 3D experiences side
by side-- 2D when you need
hands-on manipulation,
when touch is the right
experience, 3D when you just
want to show something awesome
and look around and experience
it-- the big eyeball
kicks that you're
going to get that you've
worked on your graphics so hard
in these games.
So let's get this going.
This afternoon, we're
actually doing a code lab
where you can try
doing this yourself.
If you're using Unity, adding
VR to your game is really easy.
I did the code lab myself
and was blown away--
like, man, this does
not take long at all.
No matter what, come
visit us here on the web.
You can get SDKs for
Unity, Android, and Java.
Think about what kind
of bit-sized experiences
that you can put in your game
and see what that's like.
Ah!
Dammit-- that guy again.
Anyway, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]